now that the M2 MacBook Pro has been
released and tested many people are
saying you know what I might just buy an
M1 MacBook Air for a lot less money for
example we've seen them new as low as
850 bucks and refurbished for 796
compared to 1300 so how big is the
difference really with real world use
well today that's exactly what we're
going to look at we're not going to run
any synthetic benchmarks only real world
use the type of things that people that
are buying these machines will be doing
so let's go ahead and jump in so both of
these are the base models the ones that
you can get discounted and the ones that
apple is keeping in stock and all their
stores and Best Buy Costco places like
that now as far as the design I mean
these designs have been around for many
years I have to say I do prefer the
MacBook airs wedge shape it's a little
bit more comfortable in the hand and
then if you are typing it digs less into
your palm compared to the Slate shape of
the M1 MacBook Pro now as far as weight
it's not that different so I don't think
it's a deal breaker as far as the
keyboards they are identical they both
feel great and the trackpad is slightly
larger on the MacBook Pro but have never
noticed a difference in real world use
of course we do have the touch bar on
the MacBook Pro some people do enjoy it
most people prefer having the physical
function keys on the MacBook Air as far
as the displays they are practically
identical both color accurate the only
difference is that the pro can get
brighter at 500 nits compared to 400.
now once again in real world use it is a
very small difference and it should not
be a deal breaker both of these MacBooks
have 720p webcams that are quite old
this one right here is the M1 MacBook
Air and this is the M2 MacBook Pro which
just have updated processing so it
should look a bit better but you guys
let me know what you think down below
and also what differences you heard in
microphones along with that both of
these have stereo speakers but we have
noticed that the M2 MacBook Pro actually
got slightly quieter than the previous
M1 version so let's go ahead and compare
the speakers
[Music]
[Music]
now realistically you'll be happy with
either laptop but in my opinion the M1
MacBook Air does sound a little bit
better you guys let me know what you
think getting into everyday real world
performance I have five web browsing
tabs opened up right here most people
use these systems for using Google Drive
email some YouTube listening music going
to various articles things like that so
this is a very basic setup and both of
these systems are extremely Snappy for
this kind of stuff and to be honest even
though the M2 Chip is snappier you can't
really tell a difference day to day with
these kind of tasks now one thing we
hear a lot of people using these kind of
machines for is xcode especially people
that are getting into coding and there's
a lot of them so how big of a
performance difference is there really
in our standard compiling test the M2
took two minutes and 14 seconds compared
to 2 minutes and seven seconds for the
M1 MacBook Air now that seems extremely
odd why would it be slower well we did
run this before and the M2 was faster
but that was with only X could open
nothing else and of course this time
around we do have five web browsing tabs
open which is very real world we have
that open on both systems and a lot of
our commenters said even 10 tabs is too
low when they're compiling they have 20
30 tabs open now that is because with
the base model of the M2 MacBook Pro we
only have one nand chip for the SSD
which results in slower SSD speeds and
with these eight gig models Mac OS does
have to use the ssds as RAM now I want
to show you guys that the MacBook Air
actually has more storage filled up than
the MacBook Pro has we have 91 gigs
compared to 135 available and with these
ssds if they're really full they can
slow down a bit so the advantage is with
the M2 MacBook Pro now before we run our
other real world tests we're gonna have
to transfer our test folder to these
systems I'm gonna have to delete xcode
just so we can fit this folder on here
and that's honestly one of the struggles
that you get with only having 256 gigs
of space so now let's go ahead and
transfer our PC test folder and we'll
see how long it takes it's been three
minutes so far and the M2 is starting to
slow down now it wasn't the lead and
started the transfer quicker but because
of that Nan setup it does slow down
faster whereas this one is leading by
quite a bit now even though I noticed
that the folder is actually slightly
larger about three gigs larger overall I
know what else was added to that one the
M2 took five minutes and 37.89 pretty
much 5 minutes and 38 seconds to do this
transfer compared to 3 minutes and 41
for our MacBook Air which had a slightly
larger file now the ssds are different
but their read speeds are quite similar
they're both Thunderbolt 3 external ssds
but of course if you upgrade the M2
MacBook Pro to 512 gigabytes then it
won't have that slowdown now another
thing that a lot of people do with their
MacBooks is edit photos so I have
Lightroom opened up right here and let's
test out the responsiveness of both of
these systems so as you guys could see
the M2 is loading up these 42 megapixel
images quicker and doing the effects
well that last one right there was
actually faster on the M1 so maybe I
spoke too soon let's go through a few
more of them now some people have said
well 50 pictures that's too much and to
be honest I have I don't think ever went
out in a photo shoot and loaded 50
pictures in It's always 150 200 or from
weddings of course then you're in the
thousands so 50 is very very reasonable
and probably too little now as far as
doing this kind of stuff and going in
and zooming in and using brushes things
like that you are not going to notice
very many differences between these
systems Lightroom does use graphics
performance and the M2 does have better
graphics but it doesn't need all of that
performance now where we could see a
bigger difference is when we go ahead
and Export and then we're going to be
maxing out the CPU and using the better
graphics so let's go ahead and hit
export and time it let's take a look at
the activity monitor and our M2 is using
5.6 gigabytes of swap whereas the M1 is
using just over five meaning we're
definitely using the SSD as RAM and that
makes sense with these eight gig models
totally normal because just the Mac OS
operating system by itself can use four
to five gigabytes now our M2 is quite a
bit behind which I wasn't expecting it
to be this slow and of course if we take
a look at our SSD we have 43 gigabytes
about left on the M1 and we have 41
remaining on the M2 very similar similar
as far as the storage so the only
difference is that the SSD on the M1
MacBook gear is faster with those two
Nan chips and of course we do have five
Chrome tabs in the background on both
systems set up exactly the same so we
have a video playing we have this IGN
Chrome tab we have some Apple stock we
have our Google Drive and as you guys
can see our M1 MacBook Air is being a
bit more responsive as well alright the
M1 MacBook gear is finished it took
three minutes and 31 seconds which is
definitely slower than if it was just
running by itself and our M2 took six
minutes and 46 seconds so it's not twice
as slow but it's getting close to that
and you guys saw everything on these
systems is set up the same except for
this MacBook is a lot less expensive so
how could you make the M2 MacBook Pro
faster well first off you could keep
almost nothing on your SSD these have
245 gigs once they're formatted we're
using about 200 gigs about 120 125 is
our files and then of course you have
the Mac OS you have the system data so
it's not like we overloaded these but if
you're buying a base model you're going
to have your files and programs on there
or the other option is to not have
anything else open so right now we have
these web browsing tabs we have that
song opened up right here the music in
the background Google Drive all that
kind of stuff so responsiveness now that
we're not exporting it's back to normal
both are nice and quick but we're just
gonna go ahead and close it which I
never run this way everybody's
multitasking a lot of people keep
multiple applications open now they're
using your iPhone and having apps work
that way on there so let's run this test
again all right our M2 is done that was
actually the fastest time we've ever
gone with it the Owen MacBook Air is
finishing up and it took two minutes and
21 seconds compared to 1 minute and 53
seconds for the base M2 so with the best
case scenario the M2 is 14 faster than
the M1 and that was you know by like I
said the fastest time we ever got
usually it's two minutes but when we
have five Chrome tabs open we have stuff
in the background you're multitasking
well you guys saw the difference the M1A
did slow down bottom took about a minute
longer but the M2 took I don't close to
three times longer and so even though
we've talked about the ssds and people
said we were overreacting this is just
the real world difference and it's not
like we have 10 or 20 tabs open or we're
doing something crazy this just proves
that the base M2 MacBook Pro isn't a
great multitasking machine if you're
doing productivity if you're just doing
web browsing it's completely fine so I
don't know if Apple did testing I'm sure
they do they spent 21 billion dollars in
r d last year but it's just a good way
to get people to spend more money to
upgrade their SSD to not have this issue
or Ram or both and of course it's
working because now that this info is
out people are spending more money and
they're buying the 512 models when
before the base 256s would outsell by
about three times I believe with the
MacBook Air whereas comparing both these
on the MacBook here side you can get one
for a killer deal and it holds up to
those kind of multitasking tasks and now
we're going to do a bit of simple video
editing now once again I just have Final
Cut opened up right now uh realistically
I would have web browsing tabs a lot of
times I'd have Photoshop or Lightroom
open up in the background but I feel bad
for doing tests with other stuff loaded
up because I know how much it's going to
slow down and so many people are giving
us Flack and YouTube Creator as well
that were pushing on this too much we're
being unrealistic but you guys see the
results for yourself so the first thing
I'm going to do real world test is just
stabilizing uh 4K okay video clip here
the first I'm going to do is stabilize
this video clip we know the M2 has 10
core Graphics that are much more
powerful that took 7.6 seconds compared
to 9.8 so just over a two second
difference and that is almost 30 faster
so it lines up with the differences but
this just shows you what it represents
in the real world and now I'm playing
back a five minute 4K project with a few
effects added which is very typical for
average people some people don't even
use things like color correction and
things like that both systems are
handling it perfectly and neither
machines are maxing out the graphics to
be able to do tasks like these and I
have done a lot of 4K video editing on
the base M1 MacBook gear and it's done a
surprisingly good job and now let's go
ahead and Export this five minute
project mine are usually about 10
minutes or so but depending on your
length you guys could just multiply the
results 2 minutes and 22 seconds for the
M2 and 2 minutes and 25 seconds for the
M1 MacBook Air so realistically that is
no difference and once again we shut
everything off and did not touch the
systems as this was happening now that
is not realistic we're usually working
on thumbnails in Photoshop we're
browsing the web we have stuff open we
just sit there which you should be doing
if you want the best performance at
least on the M2 so let's just open a few
tabs like we had before so we have those
opened up right here everything's
running just fine and then I also opened
up photoshop with some images as well
just like I would on a normal basis or
this could be any other application
Microsoft Office for you that you have
something open anything else really and
now let's run that export again which
isn't really super tough on the Ram uh
when we're running this just because
it's a short easy kind of test things
that normal people do right away our M1
MacBook Air is a head where 21 compared
to 10 on on the M2 and we check out the
responsiveness difference
let's go ahead and open up Chrome
lagging up right there a bit let's shift
through tabs
definitely a lot slower and these
systems are set up identically the
amount of storage we have left is
identical and here we're even seeing
some choppiness in that video I'm
clicking them at the same time you guys
are seeing the difference in real time
with no editing nothing being cut out of
this section I hit my email over here
and I mean that just shows that just
kind of speaks for itself and this is
why we've been uh really negative about
this laptop at least the base
configuration just because we don't
think that a new laptop that is more
expensive compared to a cheaper lineup
That is a year and a half older should
perform worse in any scenario this just
does not make sense and it's kind of
inexcusable for us let me open up
Photoshop again on both of these
and let's just check out a few of these
images
um I don't have any effects or anything
added anything that uses Graphics none
of that at all
right there that was pretty similar I
think the M2 is slightly faster
up the M1 beat that one out so we are
rendering the background a lot of times
we're not just leaving our computer and
waiting we're multitasking let's go back
into Final Cut oh I actually just missed
the M1 finishing up uh it took 2 minutes
and 43 seconds actually slightly faster
than that because I hit it too late and
we're at 39 right now on the M2 the M1
we gave it so much praise when it came
out the M1 air Tola people buy the base
model stick with eight gigs of RAM that
swap works so well the the system is so
responsive well this is proof right here
and everybody that's been giving us hate
on the M2 uh that we've been you know
hating on them too or been talking about
this and trying to get the word out
there this is the real world results
we're at 55 right now all right we are
done and instead of taking 2 minutes and
43 seconds on that one air actually
slightly faster than that it took five
minutes and 46 seconds
that is with Photoshop open with just
some images without you know the smart
effects and Graphics tasks and all that
in the background our five web browsing
tabs in Chrome uh Safari is not much
different we tested it out in another
video and then exporting that five
minute video now if it was a 10 or 20
minute video it hit the ram harder so it
would be a bigger difference so the M2
is faster but as long as you're only
opening one application and letting it
sit there and not do anything else and
that is extremely unrealistic now if you
know this knowledge and you have the
system you're going to want to use it
that way to get the you know proper
performance and even then it just was so
close to the M1 MacBook Air
but if you had to make a choice between
the systems the base model I just we
cannot recommend it whatsoever it is so
hard to recommend because when it's
faster it's not much faster but when
it's slower like when you're
multitasking using in real life
scenarios it can get a lot slower now
yes you have to spend more money you
cannot buy the base model if you need
the M2 Chip you need to at least spend
another 200 or another 400 but then
again Apple would want you at that point
while you're spending a lot and you
might as well just jump up to the 14
inch which is a much better machine and
that is our dilemma and for all the
people saying hey this is benchmarks
these people are pushing all these
benchmarks unreal stuff at the system
they're trying to break them you guys
are seeing this completely real time not
some tests done with nothing else open
with nothing on the SSD just Mac OS in
one program and then showing some report
off camera this is the truth so please
share this to people that are trying to
buy one of these systems because this is
your shoes and we have nothing to hide
and for you guys if you're saying the M2
is kind of disappointing I'll buy the M1
MacBook Air you are absolutely 100 right
or even more than 100 if that's possible
I mean this system for 850 bucks that's
been discounted many times on Amazon or
even less maybe under 800 refurbished
you're getting a super Snappy multitask
capable system that is great for pretty
much everything that a regular person
would do now the last thing is just
battery life this thing's been almost
dead this whole time it wasn't as
charged as this when we started not even
close the battery life is worse for a
real world mixed use you're gonna get
about eight to ten hours compared to
about 9 to 12 on the MacBook Pro because
it does have a larger battery included
so there you guys go let us know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below of course we have the M2 version
coming out soon so we'll redo the same
comparison with that system and so you
guys can check out another great video
right over there click that Circle above
if you want to see that comparison this
Max and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
foreign